[Music]
imagine hating your family
[Laughter]
i like how you like look at me just like
i know you love your family
is that a long ways from how you feel no
not really i like my family yeah they're
fine there's a lot of people that hate
their family imagine hating your family
imagine your family tell me more
i don't know
well how to what degree like to the
degree that there was a man who wanted
to escape his family and has lived in an
airport for 14 years wow why is this
this is the terminal it's a terminal guy
but not not uh uh not castaway no no
there's an there's the original terminal
guy the [ __ ] saudi arabian dude no no
this is a chinese man um another
terminal guy what do he why i think well
for 14 years he's lived in terminal for
14 years what airport is this this is in
china okay china airport china
this is the beijing capital
international airport i've been there
okay he wanted to escape there he wanted
to escape his family and go there and he
uh has never returned back to his family
after 14 years what a dick his name is
a chinese man in his 60s now and he's
lived at the airport's terminal 2.
since 2008 how's that even possible wow
you think he saw the terminal the movie
and then he goes that's a good idea did
that come out in 2008 no earlier than
it's like 2004 yeah then yes he was
definitely inspired he was inspired man
so this guy
this this is his reason for leaving
his reason for leaving
is that he wanted to smoke and drink
without his family bothering him
when the when the airport had no more
smoking he was like [ __ ] like you
shouldn't smoke he just [ __ ] moved to
a different place just smoke outside
yeah oh hi family comes down to him
about that that's the real deal yeah he
literally said that i can't go back home
because i have no freedom there my
family told me if i wanted to stay
i had to quit smoking and drinking
imagine being okay but here's the other
half of it imagine being so addicted to
smoking and drinking that you could give
up your entire family which means you're
not addicted to your family you know
that's pretty much all of skid row well
doesn't it
true doesn't his family ever go to the
airport
they're like that one goes to hong kong
we never go to that one
that terminal's empty and nobody's
they're all why go to hong kong it's
still china
because like i don't know how it works
over there compared to here but you
can't leave without buying another
ticket or some [ __ ] yeah i would assume
that uh
he wasn't buying tickets all the time i
would assume that like there might be
pockets that are outside the gateways
that he probably just stayed in as well
but i don't [ __ ] know it's not i
can't imagine not going outside like at
all yeah well this guy can this guy said
like i said my family told me if i
wanted to have to quit smoking and
drinking if i couldn't do that i had to
give them all my monthly government
allowance of 1 000 yuan which is about
i don't know 200
anyways
but then he says but then how would i
buy my cigarettes
that's a valid question for any crazy
ass person
like he's telling a journalist this like
everyone knows he's like how would i do
that huh you explain that to me yeah how
do you get yourself how do you get your
sister playing that smart news guy yeah
and he explains that uh he decided to
give up looking for work as
after he was laid off in his 40s he
struggled to keep a new job because of
being too old so he doesn't want to work
he could just be an airport janitor yeah
dude he could just literally clean up
the trash around him get paid for
his own
sleep it's pretty common for forced
retirement at 50. i got um
basically jacked by a gang of senior
citizens in china and my friend's mom
was explaining to me that there's a lot
of desolate old dudes that just [ __ ]
can't work
because there's you know there's a lot
of labor there how did you get jacked so
um me and my buddy were trying to go see
the [ __ ] great wall of china and um
this guy was like hop in the back of my
[ __ ] donkey cart
you know like we'll take you yeah and
then i'll i don't know he speaks chinese
so we rolled and then we were stopping
by statues taking pictures and we went
to a village and then we stopped at the
village and then um he's like all right
the tour's over and then they start
arguing and i'm like oh [ __ ] this
doesn't look good right i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on i'm like
what's going on he goes he pulled out
this laminated sheet of a price list and
it was like special tour of the
forbidden city 2 000 us dollars it was
just outrageous it added up to being
like 14 000 or something and i'm like
exactly i'm like
nah bro you don't even know how much u.s
dollars are this guy's making up numbers
so great good people retire on this one
he calls his dad he's like this is my
last job
why is he stephen cigar i'm out of the
business getting out after this one i
promise my last one so so they're
arguing in mandarin i don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on so i'm like i know
something's fishy here this seems like a
con man and then like thank god when i
travel like i always have a dummy wallet
with a little bit of money my real
money's elsewhere so you're trying to
fake out the people who rob you that's
smart
you gotta man cause i don't know this
area you know so like i could kick up a
store
i opened up my wallet i'm like look and
i grabbed the money [ __ ] chucked it
at him and then i'm like it has nothing
that's that's everything i got you know
and then so
obviously they took money from my friend
but the funny thing is like while
they're arguing right i notice his
backup coming and i look around and it's
literally the senior citizen of the
village just surrounding us
and it's just all old people and i'm
like this is a gang of like
asian grandpas and dads and none of them
look tough everybody looks like i could
just destroy them but i'm like a
scorpion with 50 ants you know i'm like
what am i gonna do like
and i was just like this is crazy we are
literally right now getting mugged by
cute little senior citizens you know you
should have done
tell me you're gonna go get a theater
degree and they're like oh no no no
oh no bachelor's of fine arts i have a
heart attack
liberal studies
no doctor
i
[Laughter]
when i get back to the states we tell my
friend you know his mom knows what
happened and she goes yeah like right
you know in china there's like uh this
was in like what 2005 or some [ __ ] right
she's like they're all dead by now like
for sure probably but there's like
forced retirement there's like all these
you know labor
[ __ ] human rights [ __ ] up [ __ ]
because they have just so many people
and if you're too old they're just like
we don't need you at our company buddy
we got someone younger stronger better
to do it and so you just have like all
these old folks that need some kind of
help and then they turn a crime and they
they turn to mugging tourists dude it
was the oddest [ __ ] ever such a very
very gentle mugging it was a gentle con
but at the same time i was mind blown
and then the audacity was they left
being pissed that we didn't have enough
money and they felt cheated because we
couldn't pay the bill that's like have
you guys watched a lot of the scammer
payback videos on youtube i love those
like the ones online like where he like
hacks their computer while he's talking
to him he's like i just deleted your
entire database like what you put it
back
they get all like mad at them i'm pissed
about it that they can't do the little
crime
did i love it when they turn on the
[ __ ] webcam and it's like oh that's a
nice like wallpaper you got back there
he's like
yeah you're already on camera dude what
do you think's gonna happen now
good man i love it when they start
cussing at them you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] no
[ __ ]
that's why whenever those scammers call
me kick my dog the first thing i say
like it's like it's like it's it's not
even hello right i already know because
it's a scammer i'm just like
[ __ ] you you scammer [ __ ] and
then me like you little [ __ ] i will
[ __ ] kill you
it's like yeah dude you work at nasa for
sure you know my dad got a call that i
don't know if any of you guys have got
this scam but he got the call where they
say that you're like daughters being
held hostage
so like the this dude calls my dad picks
up and my dad's a [ __ ] he's just like
a dick he like for fun he puts on a
speaker the guy's like i have your
doctor we're going to kill her unless
you pay this money my dad goes kill her
do it
go ahead do it i hate her kill her doing
a fade me a favor send me a [ __ ] mp4
of it
not an mov file don't you send me that
move you don't have a goddammit i'm on
android
i really had a girl okay oh and they
call the wrong number and your dad's
like doing they're like okay
i'm gonna have to do it he doesn't want
you he sees it on the news later that
day oops
and then the terrorists were like that
was the wrong number
[Laughter]
my dad would go oops
how did they play him off
so you're actually right uh there was
another dude uh so this chinese dude
wade doesn't have the longest tenure
living at an airport there was a turkish
man oh he's turkey leave it to the
turkish to always is that what the true
story is
so you know the movie terminal
it's based off of this guy yeah he moved
to ataturk airport
in 1991 for similar reasons to that of
ways and he lived there for 27 years oh
my god before the airport closed in 29th
oh my god and he now lives in sabiha
goxson airport oh wait no that's not the
guy
there's another guy right he got stuck
in between because his like country like
fell apart or whatever in between it was
it was i oh he was iranian that's what
it was and um
it was it was in london or paris it's
one of those it's europe it's europe
because he claimed that his mother
was uh from england
and that he needed to get to her but
then the more the journalists dug they
realized that he created this elaborate
lie oh no yeah
and he purposely lost a lot of documents
and things like that
and um man it's it's but that's where
the movie terminal is based off of this
guy's life he would eat me mcdonald's
every [ __ ] day
and then he had a little corner and that
was a terminal man yeah
wow yeah she's nuts yeah
and then so he they would try to send
them to his destination when he got
there since he didn't have the
documentation i would send him back
exactly
you know when i'm on the airplane and
the the stewardess is like you know i
just landed in l.a and she's like no you
want to hang on and we're going to be
going to colorado and i'm just like man
their days are crazy
like they wake up in orlando yeah they
maybe go to bed in denver after going
like four cities yeah
there's like a period of time that they
can't work afterwards i was talking to
like one of the attendants i forget what
there's like a turnover period where
once you land or whatever like you can't
you're not allowed to work for like x
amount of hours until you rest until you
get on the next flight or whatever so
that they avoid like overworking them i
guess i don't know how well that works
in per like in practice but he was
saying like yeah like i think it was a
hawaiian flight and i was like oh how is
this because it's like a six hour flight
you know back and forth he's like oh
yeah when i get there like the law is
that i have to like rest for x amount of
you know hours before i can book before
they'll schedule me he has to attend
every luau
authentic luau you have to stand on sit
on the beach
coconut boobs okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you